MALE SPEAKER: Let's welcome
Jeremy and the Capella team
to talk about bringing the
power of YouTube to your games.
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY WALKER: All right.
Hi, my name's Jeremy Walker.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
And as he said, I'm
going to talk you
a little bit about bringing
the power of YouTube to games.
But before I got
started I always
like to start with a demo.
And that's what we're doing
here with Capella today.
So if you're
anything like me, you
like to get your friends
together in a living room,
and talk some smack,
and play some games.
But you can't really do that
with mobile games, right?
You can do that with
consoles, but the thing
that's kind of
missing is playing
in real time against
each other, and then
being able to share your screen.
So kind of two items.
Luckily for us, the first
one is taken care of.
We're playing an Android
game called Riptide GP2.
I don't know If you guys
have heard this game.
It's pretty fun.
It's a racing game.
And they've integrated with the
Google Play Games Services API
to enable that real time
playing with each other.
But to take it a step
further and share it,
Capella put something
together where we're actually
out putting from both of
these phones to Capella.
And they're doing a little
magic with some green screens
and stuff.
And then we're sharing it up
to YouTube on a live stream.
So we have our gamers here,
and they're playing the games.
Say hello, guys, if you
can-- Kyle and David.
And then we have
[INAUDIBLE] over here.
She's running the studio.
It's called Cambria Live.
It's by Capella.
And then they're using
our live streaming API
to stream it up to YouTube.
So if the Wi-Fi is working,
and the gods are with us,
I should be able
to see this live.
Please stand by.
OK.
So the Wi-Fi is
not with us today.
Well that's OK.
We actually figured
this would happen.
This probably means the Wi-Fi in
Moscone wasn't quite up to par.
We figured this might happen,
so we recorded ahead of time
to let you see that,
yes, this does work.
So we still have
the same gamers.
You can see they're
playing right behind me.
That they're live
And [INAUDIBLE]
is working in Cambria
from Capella [INAUDIBLE]
all together and
streaming out to YouTube.
And you can see behind
me that they're actually
playing in real time.
So hopefully, this
gives you some ideas
of how you can use the YouTube
APIs with your mobile games.
And back to you, Jeremy.
All right.
So maybe next time.
But you can see that it works.
We thought that was pretty cool.
So hopefully that's
kind of got you
feeling a little more awake.
And now I'll jump
into the slides.
And hopefully, I won't
put you to sleep.
But I basically have three
things to cover today.
I'm going to cover
why you should
use YouTube with
your mobile games.
How to do it with a replay.
That's just like playing back
a highlight from your game.
And then live.
And then the last
part is a a review.
So I always like to
start with this number.
So we released this
a little while ago,
so it's a little higher now.
But we get one billion unique
users per month on YouTube.
So that's a lot
of people that are
coming to YouTube
to watch content.
And one of our biggest
categories is gaming.
So a lot of people are coming
to YouTube just, specifically,
for gaming.
And you guys probably know this.
You've probably gone there
to check out some game play
videos yourself.
But what I wanted to do is kind
of take a step back, and think
of this presentation
a little bit
differently, maybe
from your aspect.
And so I talked to some people.
And the one thing that seemed
to come up a lot for gamers
is how do I get my
game to stand out?
And so that's what I'm going
to kind of look at today.
So so I'm going
to-- let's forget
the stuff where you
follow style guidelines,
and all that stuff to
get yourself promoted.
Maybe within the play game store
or whatever, or the app store.
We're going to look at stuff
that can influence you.
So let's take a step
back and-- let's
say you're developing a game.
And usually, when I talk to
game developers, you know,
they may have like
something like video sharing
on the list of things to do.
But as you guys
know, when you get
closer to launching,
or launching,
whether that's a new game
or a new feature, you know,
you probably
something took longer
than you thought it would, have
and you have to cut things.
And maybe you have to decide
between a new level and that
enabling video sharing
or something like that.
And it usually gets cut.
And what people tell me is like
well, a minority of our users
actually use it.
So we didn't think
it was worthwhile.
We thought the extra
level or something
like that would be better.
And so, actually
looked into that.
And you'd be right.
Only 10 to 20% of users,
mobile game users,
find that feature to
be very important.
And this was from a study
that Amplifier did last year.
So this is sharing.
And what they meant
by this, it doesn't
mean like sharing
your high score,
saying, hey, I like this game.
It means sharing a screen--
three things sharing a screen
shot, but, more importantly,
sharing video replay,
or live video.
So that's-- this 10 to 20%
said it's very important.
And what this survey
wanted to try to figure out
was, you know, is it worth going
after these people, or is it
not?
So again, this is mobile
gamers only, this study.
But they dove into
a lot of questions
and they separated that out.
So what they did is they
took that group of people
and they labeled them sharers.
And then they figured
out how do they
compare to the non-sharers?
Now again, both are
mobile game players.
And what they found
is pretty interesting.
So first, sharers download
and try more games per month.
They actually play more per
week, more hours per week.
They make more purchases,
which is great, right?
That's in app in the
games themselves.
And then, lastly,
they're more social.
So they're going to share
the game play experiences
with people, not only
online but offline.
They want to recommend them,
which is also a great thing.
So you're probably thinking, OK.
So there's this subset that's
a little bit more important.
That make sense.
But I'm still on the fence.
Like it still doesn't seem
like it's worth the work.
And this one's pretty
obvious, but mobile gamers
watch game videos.
So in the survey, they ask
them a bunch of questions.
And there's a
couple that came out
that I thought were
really important.
And this is one of them.
So 65% of people, of mobile
gamers, watch video game play.
80% of the sharers
watched it, as well.
So they were a bit higher.
But what's really
interesting there,
is they broke out
the categories.
They didn't just
say video game play.
They said live streaming,
trailers, video game play.
And video replay, or
watching actual game play,
was rated number one.
It was actually
rated above trailers.
So think about
that for a second.
People-- it's more important
to them to watch the game
play than these $1,000
or million dollar
trailers that are put out.
So keep that in
the back your head.
And then what really
kind of drove this home
for me was this other
question that I found was,
when a mobile gamer
goes and watches
a game play clip, what's their
number one action afterwards?
And what they found, was
that 45% of the time they
download the game.
That was number one.
Number two is they would
share it or refer it.
And then, number three, was
they continue researching.
So think about
that for a second.
These free-- they're
making these for free,
these game play videos.
They have a high
click through rate.
I mean, you're spending
money making these trailers.
And these free things
are watched more,
and have a good
click-through rate.
Like why aren't you
taking advantage of it?
That's what I like to say.
So hopefully that at least
get you thinking about,
yeah there is a
minority of users.
But they are going to generate
a lot of videos for me
that have a lot
of ads for me that
have high click-through rates.
So that's something
to think about.
And then again, with
the YouTube API's, we
allow you to do
some extra things,
like in the description, you can
set a link to your store links.
So they can click right
there and get right to it.
So there's a lot of good
things you can do there.
Anyway hopefully that
kind of gives you
an idea of why
you'd want to do it.
So now I'm going to give
you some examples of how
it was done, both
in replay and live.
So any you guys play football?
And not American
football, obviously.
So actually FIFA did this in
2013 and their game on iOS.
They actually do in
the newer one, too.
But they allow you
to share on YouTube.
So if you score a goal,
you can share that.
And one of my Polish
colleagues is playing Poland.
And he's pretty excited here.
He scored a goal.
So he wanted to share
that experience.
And what they let you do
is they let you go back
and change the
camera angles so you
can make it a little
bit more interesting.
And you can see there, in the
lower right, after he scores,
you can click on a button
there to upload it to YouTube.
And the first time you
go through, obviously, it
asks you, you know, do you want
to upload this to your account.
And you can.
And then on the right
side, you can actually
see the screen shot of this
actual game play up on YouTube.
What you don't see there is a
description which points back.
So that anybody that comes
to see this and likes this
can click through right there.
And install the game.
And you guys have kids?
If you do, you probably
heard this game, Talking Tom.
So this is a little game
where you talk to it
and it reads it back to
you in a funny voice.
And it has a whole
bunch of animals.
It's got some really, really
funny things that people
have done with it, or their
singing, or comedy bits.
I suggest you check it out.
I can't show it here
because I'd probably
get in trouble with HR.
But definitely check it out.
And they actually integrate.
You can see on the
upper left there,
they integrate a
little record button
so you can record
your interactions.
And they actually have accounted
for 1.4 million interactions
uploaded to YouTube.
But what's more
interesting is they're
getting over 25 million
views per month.
I think they said they had
800 million views so far.
So think about that.
A couple of these videos have
hundreds of thousands of views.
Like they're making stuff
and it's going viral.
And Talking Tom is
taking advantage of that.
So anyway, hopefully, that
gets you thinking a little bit
about that.
So how did they do that?
So there's basically two
parts to sharing video
from your game.
One part is kind of
separate from YouTube,
and the other part
is with YouTube.
So I'm going to go through
kind of a high view
because we don't have
of a lot of time.
But the first thing you're going
to want to do-- this example
is using Unity.
So you need to get--
basically, create a video.
That's step one.
So you need to grab the
audio and video frames.
You need to pipe them
through something
that will encode them for you.
You can use web m
or maybe FFmpeg,
if that's better for you.
In this case, encoding to VP8
for the video, and then Vorbis
for the audio.
And you put in a
container, like web m.
And then bam, you
have your video file.
Now is when our API step in.
And you can use-- we have tons
of client libraries in all
the major languages.
And we've written
samples in all of them.
So it's pretty easy for you
just go, pick up an API sample,
make some minor
modifications, and you're
pretty much ready go.
So that's pretty much it.
It's a RESTful
API, but, again, we
have client libraries to
handle a lot of this for you.
Now, let's say,
that's a lot of work.
And you're like, I don't
want to make the videos.
There's actually companies out
there that do this for you.
So Everyplay's a good example.
They actually
provide an SDK where
they do everything for you.
So they make the video.
And then they allow the
user to upload to YouTube.
And they've done this
for a lot of games.
I'm sure you guys
recognize this one.
This is one.
And then there's another
company called kamcord
that does the same thing.
They have a bunch
of games as well.
Trial Xtreme 3 is one.
So if you do a really cool
trick, you can share it up.
And again, these are just SDKs
that you add to your game.
And they take care
of all this for you.
So at least for
Replay, hopefully, that
gives you a little bit of an
idea of some of the things
you can do.
So live is a little
bit different.
We have a couple
people that do it.
So Elgato is a big one.
They're actually
separate hardware.
But they allow you to stream
live from their device
up to YouTube.
Now you can do it with a
console, or it's mobile.
If you want to do
something a little bit more
like you saw here with Capella,
they have a live studio,
where you can do all
sorts of crazy stuff
with the green screen, crop out
people, put text, and then live
stream right up.
Wow how did they do that?
So this one is our-- actually
our live streaming API.
Pretty straightforward.
There's three main
parts to it, really,
probably only two
you'll be using.
But you create a broadcast
bind a stream to it,
and you're pretty much set.
There is a cue point,
but that's for ads,
and not everyone uses that.
So anyway, that hopefully
gives you some ideas for replay
and live.
You could do some live
stuff on the device
with the new version of Android.
And screen share, you can
do some stuff with that.
But you do have to be
aware that it's obviously
pretty-- encoding a video can
be kind of hard and on a phone,
so you got to be careful
about how you do it.
And if you're
interested in finding
about more details about
replay, in doing that,
we do have an I/O
talk, where we go
much more into detail on that.
So review.
Empower your shares.
Yes, they are a minority.
But they spend more money,
they find more games,
and they'll share it.
They'll make these free
advertisements for you
that have good
click-through rates.
And they're more important
to the mobile gamers
then trailers.
Now I'm not saying
trailers aren't important.
They are important.
But game play is
even more important.
Three times.
So this, just in the
last year, subscriptions
for gaming channels have
tripled in the last year.
So gaming is a huge
deal on YouTube.
Take advantage of it.
If you want to find out
more about the tools,
just go in your favorite search
engine and search YouTube API.
It'll probably be the
first thing that shows up.
We have samples, libraries,
all that great stuff.
And if you want to follow
more information on YouTube
and the developer community,
just go to YouTube-- oop,
sorry, youtube.com/dev.
And we have a Google+
and Twitter handle.
So thank you.
Oh we have some
extra schwag, too.
So after the next
presentation, if you
want to get some stickers and
pins for free, come on up.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]